hello children this is a story of power
and corruption
and like every great fable there will be
morals to the story
how good intentions go bad how private
industry seeks to cheat the government
and how lying and cheating will
pay payoff in this world let's just be
honest this is the story
of the little defense contractor who
[Music]
could
[Music]
so let's begin at the beginning atlantic
diving supply was a tiny mom and pop
shop out of virginia beach just getting
by when they discovered something
amazing they could win government funds
through military equipment contracts see
the government each year has certain
contracts earmarked for companies below
a certain size so that
big defense contractors can't outbid and
bully everyone it's a way to keep the
playing field
fair now atlantic diving supply who
we'll be referring to sometimes as ads
figured
why not try their hand at bidding for
some of these and so they did
and they won and little by little ads
took on more and more of these contracts
to supply things like boots and various
equipment to the government
slowly they grew from a five-person
company into over 300 people
and not only that their revenues started
ballooning as well
wasn't before long their revenues
exceeded over a billion dollars which is
really incredible coming from such
humble beginnings of a small dive shop
and
really it's the american dream right and
soon big defense contractors were
waiting for atlantic diving supply
to join the big leagues it was time for
ads to grow up
but here's the thing atlantic diving
supply they didn't want to grow they
didn't
want to compete in the big leagues they
were hooked on small business contracts
getting them is so much
easier and their revenue streams were
hugely reliant on that sweet sweet
government
cash so they had a problem how do you
continue growing a business and make
more and more money
without hiring more people and becoming
classified as a big business
see the regulation on what makes a big
business versus small business is
fundamentally regulated by the small
business association and generally the
guideline worth looking at is
500 people or fewer is considered to be
a small business so
as long as atlantic diving supply could
keep their employees below 500 they
could continue getting defense contracts
for small businesses and that's exactly
what they did
this is ads ads fulfills a mission here
at home
too we contribute to the regional
economy by providing good jobs to 400
people
to 400 people to 400 people but to those
paying attention
things looked strange even as their
hiring slowed
their revenues kept increasing from one
billion dollars to
in 2019 they hit a record-breaking 3.2
billion dollars in government contracts
according to pogo
so how are they doing this well no one
knew
until someone blew the whistle see
someone came out
and said that this little mom and pop
shop that everyone thought of is
cute small they were up to something
dirty
they had a network of small companies
they weren't reporting because they knew
if they did
they'd be considered a large business a
network that allegedly included over 900
people
basically working on behalf of ads and
that weren't
reported this network would win
contracts for ads but it wasn't
disclosed
and if you can't already tell saying
you're a small business while actually
being a large business with shell
companies to win easy government
contracts away from small businesses is
actually super illegal a network of
companies like
sdk solutions bid for small contracts in
the case of sdk solutions since they
were a
woman-owned company they bid for defense
contracts earmarked for women
which they would then give over and work
with ads to fulfill
now of course you can't do this but it
was never disclosed
and this is only the start of the
corruption not only did sdk solutions
work with ads
they also weren't actually owned and
operated by a woman i mean it was
technically in name only the owner was
a woman but she was a figurehead her
husband khalil
actually hatched this plan years before
in order to win government contracts he
had her sign saying that she was the
owner and making all the decisions when
in fact
she was not she was just a puppet to win
easy government contracts
but sdk solutions isn't the only one
another small business
card was also set up in working with ads
to get minority-owned government
contracts
this conspiracy was then aided and
abetted by local politician
ron villanueva who helped these two
shell companies get these contracts at
the political level
eventually they were sued under the
false claims act and ron villanueva was
criminally charged
ron villanueva will spend the next two
and a half years of his life
behind bars villanueva participated in a
nine-year conspiracy involving more than
80 million dollars in fraudulently
obtained government contracts
here i am i am been held accountable for
these things and
look forward to doing my time and
but what happened to our little mom and
pop shop ads did they get shut down did
did they lose their almost laughable
small business status
well no after years of litigation
they admitted no guilt they instead paid
20 million dollars to make the case go
away in a settlement and if you aren't
familiar
when you settle you don't admit guilt it
doesn't mean you didn't do it
and especially when you're paying 20
million dollars we can infer
why you would pay that kind of money to
make a case go away but they admitted
no guilt and the prosecution of course
they heralded this as a big win for the
little guy
a big score in the name of fairness and
justice the justice department remarked
in a press release last year that the
settlements rank as
the largest false claims act recovery
based on allegations of small business
contracting fraud but
others are less optimistic see the
problem is
20 million dollars to a company with 3.2
billion
in government contracts is really just a
drop in the bucket and since atlantic
diving supply admitted no guilt our
not so little little defense contractor
is still technically considered a small
business according to the small business
association which means
they're still winning contracts away
from actual small businesses
this is despite the fact that the small
business administration themselves their
inspector general in 2017 said the
action of
ads and its affiliated entities deprived
legitimate small businesses of valuable
federal
contracting opportunities exactly and at
this point
it seems like ads has so much money from
these lucrative government contracts
that they can basically
buy their small business status forever
because no matter how much trouble they
get in no matter how much evidence the
opposing side has
they can simply pay their way out in a
settlement
and the unfairness of this tactic of
pretending to be a small business while
actually using the muscle of a
billion-dollar large company
is so hilariously against the original
intentions of a small business contract
that let me remind you we're
foundational for letting ads grow in the
first place
it's really hard to express the irony
here but i'll try
it's like a high school basketball
league which has
age limits obviously to keep things fair
but there's a player
who refuses to get off the court even
after they turn 18
and every year while the other kids stay
the same size
this player gets faster and stronger and
better until
they're basically just dunking on little
children it sounds pretty ridiculous
right but that's
basically what's going on here remember
what the inspector general said the
actions of ads and affiliated entities
deprived legitimate small businesses of
valuable federal contracting
opportunities
oh and by the way just to throw a little
salt in the wound
remember the ppp program the government
just rolled out for small businesses you
know
covered relief loans for for these small
businesses who need help you know you're
just little your little restaurant right
yeah our little defense contractor with
3.2 billion dollars in federal contract
they just got a two to five million
dollar loan let me let me repeat that
while hard-working americans are
struggling to get loans for their own
small businesses
a 3.2 billion dollar revenue defense
contractor
is once again posturing as a small
business needing help
so to conclude what have we learned
today well
we've learned that cheating the system
can often be a very very
lucrative thing in addition if it's
lucrative enough
you can pay your way out of getting in
trouble
when you finally get found out see
that's what people don't tell you they
say eventually you'll get caught
but they don't tell you that if you're
big enough you can buy your way out of
it
and that concludes the story of the
little defense contractor
who could thanks for listening guys i
hope you sleep well tonight
see you next time stephen stephen
stephen what am i to do with you
i hear you're a little bit down i
understand
pandemic everything going on but here's
the thing
steven going to like and subscribe
because you're a cool guy
and you're on the ball i'm going to make
this happen everybody loves you
so just have faith stick with it as i
said
i'll be watching
[Music]
[Music]